die zentrale der frankfurter
arbeiterwohlfahrt hier sollen jahrelang
millionen euro veruntreut worden sein
die eigentlich dafür gedacht waren
menschen zu helfen
mehrere führungskräfte stehen im
mittelpunkt des skandals
es geht unter anderem um mehr als 1,6
millionen euro für überhöhte gehälter
und dienstwagen wie ein weißer jaguar
mindestens 2.000.000 nachgewiesener
schaden in der flüchtlingshilfe 0,9
millionen für undurchsichtige zahlungen
an die awo wiesbaden außerdem geht es um
vetternwirtschaft fragwürdige
beraterverträge und aus gehebelte
kontrollen entstandene gesamtschaden
laut awo mehr als sechs millionen euro
das vertrauen in die awo als
gemeinnützige organisation ist
angeschlagen
uns liegt eine anonyme strafanzeige vor
darin steht dass die frühere führung
teilweise vergütungen von 300.000 euro
pro jahr bezogen haben soll mehr als
doppelt so viel wie üblich
aufklären und transparenz in die
finanzen bringen das versprechen im märz
doch als die frage auf das eigene gehalt
kommt ist es schnell vorbei mit
offenheit kann sich dadurch das leben
sich hat erstellen lassen wir uns
vertrag haben können sie stundenlang
ungefähr ansätzen bei der hälfte von dem
was ich finde stunde zahlen natürlich
sagt ich habe ja eben begründet dass es
hier um interims vorstand geht und dass
es das video an einem bestehenden
arbeitsverhältnis orientieren dass ich
während gehälter zum beispiel bei
börsennotierten firmen längst offen
gelegt werden müssen dürfen die neuen
vorstände hier schweigen und das obwohl
ihre gehälter größtenteils durch
öffentliche gelder bezahlt werden
einrichtungen der großen
wohlfahrtsverbände sind aus dem sozialen
leben nicht wegzudenken
in frankfurt betreibt die awo
beispielsweise pflegeheimen
behinderteneinrichtungen kitas und
jugendhilfe drehen können wir dort wegen
corona nicht über wochen recherchieren
wir wie es zu dem skandal kommen konnte
wir stoßen auf ein riesen netz an
machenschaften und verstrickungen bei
der arbeiterwohlfahrt in südhessen bis
hoch in die politik selbst die frau des
frankfurter oberbürgermeisters soll als
kita leiterin von einem zu hohen gehalt
und einem dienstwagen profitiert haben
die awo frankfurt soll jahrelang
öffentliche gelder für fingierte
leistungen bekommen haben die sie so
nicht alle erbracht haben soll
die awo prüft nach eigenen angaben
selbst inwieweit es beispielsweise in
der flüchtlingshilfe oder in kitas zu
unregelmäßigkeiten in abrechnungen
gekommen ist zum beispiel ob teure
küchen abgerechnet und billige eingebaut
wurden
wir sind auf dem weg zu einer sitzung
des ortsvereins der awo in frankfurt
nied zur basis der awo
alle hier arbeiten und engagieren sich
ehrenamtlich sie organisieren
seniorentreffs fahrten schulranzen
aktionen und weihnachtsfeiern völlig
unentgeltlich umso wütender ist der
vorstand des ortsvereins über die
selbstbereicherung in der frankfurter
zentrale
das mitgekriegt habe das war ende 20 90
gewesen und jetzt da dachte ich hier
kann es nicht mehr mitarbeiten diesmal
wollte hinschmeißen sagt das war es
gewesen
ich finde und das macht mich immer
sprachlos es hat eigentlich mit der
basisarbeit im ortsverband gar nichts zu
tun
und das ist eigentlich schade dass leute
uns manchmal so ein bisschen alle in
einen topf werfen
der ortsverein bekommt die enttäuschung
der basis ab allein hier sind 50
awo-mitglieder nach dem skandal
ausgetreten
eine katastrophe für das engagement
derjenigen die übrig bleiben
ich wünsche mir groß mögliche aufklärung
und ich wünsche mir auch zum teil einen
anderen weg der eingeschlagen wird
diejenigen die sich vielleicht bedient
haben müssen wissen dass da irgendwas
falsch gelaufen ist weil ich muss ja
daraus lernen
die aufarbeitung geht meines erachtens
nicht wirklich so schnell wie es mir
wünsche
aufklärung fordert auch yanki pürsün er
ist für die fdp sowohl stadtverordneter
in frankfurt als auch
landtagsabgeordneter in wiesbaden
seit jahren beschäftigt er sich mit
wohlfahrtsverbänden und hat sich als
oppositionspolitiker der aufarbeitung
des skandals verschrieben
wir treffen ihn im hessischen landtag
der skandal ist ein riesengroßes
geflecht von interessen und jeden tag
kommt ein neuer aspekt hinzu man erkennt
noch mehr verflechtungen zwischen den
akteuren das geht so weit dass ist sogar
die die stadtspitze von frankfurt und
wiesbaden berührt überhaupt so weit
kommen es gibt auch kontrollen
leider hat die politik da viel zu viel
vertrauen in ein solches
sozialunternehmen da wird gesagt wir
geben der awo diese summe was sie im
detail mit dem geld machen wird nicht
kontrolliert
dass die awo dann aber intern ein teil
des geldes nutzen kann um ihre eigene
geschäftsführung zu optimieren größere
autos höhere gehälter zulagen dieses
jenes und so weiter da schaut die
politik leider gar nicht hin
in deutschland übernehmen seit mehr als
100 jahren die sechs großen träger der
freien wohlfahrtspflege einen großteil
der sozialen dienste die caritas
diakonie das deutsche rote kreuz
arbeiterwohlfahrt der paritätische und
die zentralwohlfahrtsstelle der juden
sie betreiben kitas krankenhäuser
pflegeeinrichtungen betreuen geflüchtete
drogenabhängige oder obdachlose menschen
und bekommen dafür öffentliche gelder
gebe ist die wohlfahrtspflege nicht
müsste der staat sich vielmehr selbst
kümmern ein zusätzlicher finanz und
verwaltungsaufwand
dafür genießen die
wohlfahrtsorganisationen bestimmte
privilegien und steuervorteile
sie können ihre organisationsform nach
bedarf wählen und sich entweder als
gemeinnützige gmbh oder als
gemeinnütziger verein organisieren
als gemeinnütziger verein unterliegen
sie beispielsweise dem steuergeheimnis
und müssen keine bilanzen
veröffentlichen
gesetze sind nicht ausreichend wenn wir
das gemeinnützigkeit privileg haben
das bedeutet dass man besser behandelt
wird als andere organisation dann bin
ich der meinung soll auch ein bürger
wissen können sind ja eigentlich noch
gemeinnützig geben die eigentlich das
geld so aus wie sie es versprochen haben
auf der grundlage wie sie das geld über
bekommen haben also ich will nicht nur
in der transparenz für die politik
spielt transparenz für die bürger
genaue zahlen werden nicht erhoben aber
experten schätzen dass jedes jahr 50 bis
80 milliarden euro in der branche
umgesetzt werden
der großteil kommt aus öffentlichen
geldern und der sozialversicherung
spenden machen nur einen kleinen teil
aus
warum sorgt die politik da nicht mit
gesetzen für mehr transparenz
der skandal in frankfurt ist kein
einzelfall auch bei der awo in
mecklenburg vorpommern und in thüringen
gibt es aktuelle untreuevorwürfe und
auch in der geschichte anderer verbände
der wohlfahrtspflege wie dem roten kreuz
der diakonie und der caritas findet man
ähnliche fälle
immer wieder geht es um nicht
nachvollziehbare gehälter protzige
dienstwagen und
selbstbedienungsmentalität möglich sind
viele dieser skandale auch weil sich die
vereine selbst kontrollieren sollten und
externe kontrollen fehlen
wir fahren nach köln zum institut der
deutschen wirtschaft eine der wenigen
wissenschaftler in deutschland der sich
mit den komplizierten sonder regelungen
der wohlfahrtsverbände auskennt ist
wirtschaftsethiker professor dominik
enste
er hat vor allem die ökonomisierung der
wohlfahrtsverbände erforscht von der
geschichte der sozialen der
wohlfahrtspflege der wohlfahrtsverbände
her kann man tatsächlich davon ausgehen
dass sie eher getrieben sind davon etwas
gutes zu tun
die wohlfahrtsverbände waren lange fast
monopolanbieter nachdem der start in
diese aufgabe übertragen hat dh sie
hatten eigentlich keine konkurrenz kann
dann bewerbt aber mittlerweile ist es
eben ein normaler markt geworden indem
man dienstleistung anbietet mittlerweile
gibt es private anbieter die pflegeheim
mit kitas und so weiter anbieten
das heißt es eine neue
wettbewerbssituation das große problem
in diesem kontext ist aber dass die
wohlfahrtsverbände selber im laufe der
letzten jahrzehnte sich kaum verändert
haben dass sie vielfach noch strukturen
haben die in diesen modernen
erfordernissen des marktes nicht gerecht
werden der ökonom nennt uns ein beispiel
für diese veralteten strukturen immer
noch sei ein großteil aller
wohlfahrtsorganisationen als verein
organisiert auch bei der awo das
bedeutet dass lediglich ehrenamtliche
vereins mitglieder die aufsicht über
hauptamtliche geschäftsführer hätten
externe kontrollen seien laut
vereinsrecht nicht verpflichtend
außerdem müssten bilanzen nicht
veröffentlicht werden
sozialunternehmen in der freien
wirtschaft werden hingegen schon seit
jahrzehnten von professionellen
wirtschaftsprüfern geprüft und müssen
finanzen offenlegen
fassen wir zusammen für
wohlfahrtsverbände gelten weniger
strenge transparenz regeln als für
private anbieter vor allem wenn sie als
verein organisiert sind
das vereinsrecht sieht außerdem keine
verpflichtenden externen kontrollen vor
mitglieder kontrollieren sich hier
gegenseitig experten die die branche gut
kennen wie professorin birgit weitemeier
fordern seit jahren dies zu ändern
für die wohlfahrtsorganisation die als
verein organisiert sind und das sind
sehr viele ist das grundproblem dass die
gesetzlichen regelungen 120 jahre alt
sind
sie passen nicht mehr und müssen
dringend reformiert werden wir haben
natürlich eine vereinslandschaft die
sich seitdem verändert hat da gibt es
also immer noch die ganz kleinen
und da gibt es inzwischen die
millionenschweren vereine und da müssen
diese regeln einfach nachziehen bisher
gelten für millionenschwere wohlfahrt
für eine gleiche regeln wie zb für
kleine sportvereine oder kegelclubs doch
gesetzesänderungen sind kompliziert es
müssten das vereinsrecht das
handelsgesetz und weil es um die
gemeinnützigkeit geht auch das
steuerrecht verändert werden
[Musik]
die politik tritt seit jahren auf der
stelle und es gibt in diesem wichtigen
bereich immer noch gesetze die 100 jahre
und älter sind
es fehlt an zuständigkeit außerdem
nennen fast alle experten mit denen wir
sprechen im interview auch noch einen
anderen grund warum sich nichts ändert
und zum anderen gibt es halt auch enge
verflechtungen zwischen
wohlfahrtsverbänden und politikern so
das ist vielleicht da manchmal auch an
sensibilität mangelt noch mal kritisch
bestehende strukturen oder auch ausgaben
ins gericht zu gehen
[Musik]
das hat man ja in frankfurt bei dem
skandal sehr deutlich gesehen da war
zwischen der schon dass die stadt
frankfurt aber auch der stadt wiesbaden
und der awo ein sehr enges verhältnis
das de facto alle durchaus vorhandenen
kontrollen mechanismen außer kraft
gesetzt hat wie eng sind die
verbindungen zwischen politik und
wohlfahrtsverbänden
wir schauen in frankfurt nacht uns fällt
auf dass mehr als zwei drittel der
abgeordneten der frankfurter spd
fraktion gleichzeitig awo mitglied sind
die frankfurter spd fraktion teilt uns
dazu mit sollte es in welchem fall auch
immer interessenkonflikte geben wird der
jeweilige stadtverordnete an den
diskussionen und abstimmungen nicht
teilnehmen
auch oberbürgermeister peter feldmann
von der spd war bei einer stiftung der
awo angestellt und steht momentan
politisch unter druck
auch weil seine frau als leiterin einer
awo kita zeitweise ein überhöhtes gehalt
bezogen haben soll und einen dienstwagen
bekam nach möglichen
interessenkonflikten gefragt antwortet
peter feldmann
seit beendigung meines arbeitsvertrages
mit der awo pflege ich keine amtlichen
verbindungen zu den dort
verantwortlichen auch im bundestag
zählen wir die angaben auf der website
durch von 709 bundestagsabgeordneten
sind mehr als 140 über eine
mitgliedschaft oder ein amt mit
wohlfahrt zu organisationen wie diakonie
caritas deutsches rotes kreuz oder
anderen verbunden
insgesamt also jeder fünfte abgeordnete
in berlin sind wir mit dem
bundesvorsitzenden der awo wolfgang
stadler verabredet gegenüber den starken
orts und kreisverbänden hat er kein
durchgriffsrecht dennoch fühlt er sich
für den ruf der awo verantwortlich wenn
man sich jetzt das gesamtgebilde abo in
deutschland im jahr 2020 jahren schaut
sind die strukturen zu intransparent
frankfurt und wiesbaden war für uns der
der super gau es war so auszudrücken was
mir wichtig ist die arbeiterwohlfahrt in
deutschland ist ist nicht das was wir in
frankfurt wiesbaden und führenden erlebt
haben
die arbeiterwohlfahrt macht eine
wirklich super gute arbeit wir haben
tausende hunderttausende ehrenamtliche
und wir haben auch sehr sehr gute
führungskräfte die angemessen bezahlt
werden und die die wirklich ihren guten
einen guten job machen
zurück bei der awo frankfurt zur
erinnerung hier soll der alte
geschäftsführer vergütungen von 300.000
euro im jahr bezogen haben wohl gemerkt
in einem awo-kreisverband von denen es
in deutschland 403 gibt was hat sich
seit den skandalen verändert bei einem
ortstermin in einem altenheim treffen
wir die neuen verantwortlichen der awo
frankfurt wieder sechs monate sind seit
der ersten pressekonferenz vergangen
ich freue mich über den spendenscheck
hat die awo für eine neue gartenlaube
bekommen in der die bewohnerinnen und
bewohner des awo heim schöne stunden
genießen sollen
steffen kollmann ist mittlerweile nicht
mehr interimsvorstand sondern reguläre
vorstand der awo frankfurt für die
nächsten fünf jahre
wir waren ja von einem halben jahr das
letzte mal bei ihnen auf der
pressekonferenz
damals hat er das thema transparenz und
wie geht es jetzt weiter mit der
frankfurter eine große rolle gespielt
wie ist denn da der stand der
aufarbeitung wir haben jetzt so weit wir
das sehen können sämtliche themen gehalt
innerhalb unserer
verwaltung unsere organisation bereinigt
auch die themen dienstwagen und zulagen
und wir haben jetzt auch eben einen
vorstand für die nächsten fünf jahre
bestellt sodass wir jetzt auf der basis
der aufarbeitung eben auch an die
zukunft denken können wie wir die awo
weiter gestalten wollen jetzt ging es
die ganze zeit um völlig überhöhte
gehälter wie viel verdienen sie denn
mein jahres kalt sind 130000 euro haben
sie als interimsvorstand bekommen
das waren mehr hat sich daran orientiert
an dem was ich in der bank verdient habe
und wie viel war dass das war ja das
waren jetzt kann ich jetzt gar nicht
aufs jahr von 180000 euro
das waren dann unter gerechnet 14.000
euro monatlich
wir reden darüber dass steuergelder
eingesetzt werden beitragszahler gelder
spendengelder ist dann ein monatliches
gehalt von 14.000 euro an der stelle
gerechtfertigt aus meiner sicht war es
damals gerechtfertigt und zwar aus
folgendem grund die arbeiterwohlfahrt
befand sich wirklich am rande des
abgrundes
ohne das absolut schnelle und drastische
eingreifen von professionellen managern
wäre die awo jetzt wahrscheinlich
insolvenz wie es jetzt die kontrolle
geregelt also es gibt spielregeln was
darf der vorstand und wo müssen wir das
präsidium mit einbinden und das haben
wir an der grenze 50.000 euro fest
gemacht und das ist einfach auch etwas
was gang und gäbe ist und was es vorher
nicht gab
die skandale der letzten jahrzehnte
haben gezeigt dass vor allem das
veraltete vereinsrecht und das fehlen
verpflichtende kontrollen
selbstbedienung bei wohlfahrtsverbänden
ermöglichen können
es geht um milliarden steuer
sozialversicherungs und spendengelder
gesetze sollten endlich sicherstellen
dass das geld immer bei denen ankommt
für die es bestimmt ist
[Musik]